>> Tucker: BIGGEST CRIME OF OUR
LIFETIME.
BILL MELUGIN, THANKS SO MUCH.
CHRIS BECK IS A NAME YOU MAY
RECOGNIZE.
A HIGHLY DECORATED NAVY SEAL.
HE BECAME FAMOUS BECAUSE HE
ANNOUNCED HE WAS TRANSITIONING,
CALLING HIMSELF KRISTIN BECK.
CNN MADE A FILM ABOUT HIM.
IN THAT FILM, HE IDENTIFIED AS A
WOMEN AND WASN'T SURE WHAT THE
TERM TRANS GENDER MEANT.
>> IT'S HARD TO EXPLAIN.
PEOPLE ASK ME.
THEY SAY I DON'T UNDERSTAND
TRANSGENDE
TRANSGENDER.
THE ONLY THING I CAN TELL THEM,
I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT
TRANSGENDER IS.
I KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IT'S THIS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT COMES
FROM OR WHY.
>> Tucker: SO CHRIS BECK HAS HAD
TEN YEARS TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
HE LOOKS BACK AND BELIEVE AND
HAVE SAID THE WHOLE PROCESS OF
TRANSITIONING DESTROYED HIS
LIFE.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH ROBBY STAR
BUCK, BECK SAID THIS.
"EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED TO ME
THE LAST TEN YEARS DESTROYED MY
LIFE.
I DESTROYED MY LIFE.
I'M NOT A VICTIM.
I DID THIS TO MYSELF, BUT I HAD
HELP."
CHRIS BECK JOINS US NOW.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IT'S A POIGNANT STORY.
WHEN YOU SAID YOU HAD HELP, WHAT
DID YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> TRANSGENDER ORIGINALLY
STARTED OUT BASIC AND VERY RARE.
NOW IT'S KIND OF MORPHED INTO AN
IDEOLOGY.
THAT'S WHAT I'M SPEAKING OUT
ABOUT.
A LOT OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE OUT
THERE, GREAT FOLKS.
THE IDEOLOGY IS WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
IT'S BEING PUSHED IN SCHOOLS AND
YOUNG TEEN ANGERS ARE HAVING
SURGERIES BECAUSE IT'S AN
AFFIRMATION.
ONCE A TEENAGER WALKS IN AN
OFFICE AND THE PARENTS SAY NO,
THE DOCTOR CAN OVERRIDE THAT.
THAT IS A PROBLEM.
THEN HE ALSO SAYS THE IDEOLOGY,
WHAT'S GOING ON TO PROVE IT IS
LIKE WHAT HAS HAMMED TO ME.
AS SOON AS I STARTED SPEAKING
OUT AND SAY I THINK THE TEENS
NEED MORE TIME, THEY ALSO NEEDED
TO RECLASSIFY TRANSGENDER,
GENDER DYSPHORIA.
USED TO BE THE PSYCHOLOGIST
MANUAL FOR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
NOW THEY HAVE GOTTEN RID OF
THAT.
AS SOON AS SOMEBODY SAID YOU'RE
TRANSGENDER, YOU'RE GOING TO
START PUSHING THE SURGERY.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO STOP.
A LOT OF CRAZY PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT ARE TRANSGENDER AND NOT.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT CNN, THEY TAKE
SOUND BITES AND TALK ABOUT IT
ONE-SIDED.
TALK ABOUT THE PROS OF
TRANSGENDE
TRANSGENDER.
NOW ON FOX, I DON'T WANT IT TO
HAPPEN THE OPPOSITE WAY.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE EMOTIONS OUT
OF THIS.
LOOK AT IT AS A MEDICAL TEAM.
LET'S LOOK AT IT THROUGH A
DIFFERENT SCOPE.
I DON'T WANT THIS TO BE
POLITICAL.
I DON'T WANT TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
TO BE HARMED.
IF YOU'RE DOING THIS TO KIDS,
IT'S WRONG.
I HAVE A NAVY SEAL FRIEND OF
MINE, A VERY GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE.
HE HAS A DAUGHTER.
THE DAUGHTER WAS A TOM BOY.
YOU COULD SEE IT.
SHE WAS HAPPY.
SHE HAD A DOUBLE MASTECTOMY AT
16 YEARS ODD.
NOW THIS PERSON IS 20.
WHO KNOWS WHO WILL HAPPEN.
THEY DO IT OR HORMONE BLOCKERS
AND PUBERTY BLOCKERS.
IT STERILIZES THESE KIDS.
SO WE'RE DOING TO HAVE ALL OF
THESE CHILDREN IN FIVE OR TEN
YEARS THAT ARE BEING TOLD ONE
SIDE OF THE STORY AND THEY'RE
GOING WELL, THAT'S ME.
THEY'RE NOT BEING TOLD STORIES
LIKE ME AND NOT BEING TOLD
STORIES THAT ARE B TRANSITIONS.
THEY HIDE THE FACT THAT I EVEN
EXIST.
THEY ALSO SAY I HATE TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE.
I DON'T HATE TRANSGENDER PEOPLE.
I WANT PEOPLE TO SLOW DOWN.
I WANT THE DOCTORS TO SEEING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
IN PSYCHOLOGY, TAKE A LOOK AT
BODY DISORDER.
A MYRIAD OF THINGS YOU CAN LOOK
AT THAT WE REALLY HAVE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT.
SO WHAT I'M TELLING YOU, THE
MEDICAL INDUSTRY AND PARENTS,
YOU NEED TO WAKE UP.
YOU NEED TO KNOW THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION OUT THERE
THAT IS BEING HIDDEN.
I WANT YOU TO SEARCH THAT
INFORMATION.
IF YOU'RE A TEEN, LOOK AT THE
STORIES LIKE CHLOE COLE.
SHE'S 18 OR 19 NOW.
I THINK SHE HAD A DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY AT 14 OR 15 YEARS
OLD.
SHE'S OUT HERE SPEAKING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE SHE'S AN ADULT NOW.
SO SHE'S GETTING ALL OF THIS
DONE AS A TEENAGER.
WHERE DOES THAT PUT THE MEDICAL
INDUSTRY?
SHE WAS NOT A CONSENTING ADULT.
SHE GOT LIFE-ALTERING SURGERY.
SHE GOT BASICALLY CASTRATED AS A
TEENAGER WITH ALL OF THESE DRUGS
AND THIS STUFF THEY'RE GIVING
THEM.
WHY?
ALL I'M SPEAKING OUT ABOUT IS
THAT.
I WANT PEOPLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
BOTH SIDES.
I WANT YOU TO SEE THE CNN SIDE
AND I WANT YOU TO SEE THE FOX
SIDE.
RIGHT NOW THIS IS NOT POLITICAL.
I DON'T WANT TO BE EMOTIONAL OR
TURN IN TO SOMETHING BIGGER THAN
IT IS.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE NEWS.
IF DOCTORS WOULD BE HONEST AND
GIVE THE ENTIRE STORY, I
WOULDN'T BE ON HERE RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD HAVE GONE ABOUT MY LIFE
QUIETLY, I WOULD HAVE BEEN ON MY
FARM.
YOU NEVER WOULD HAVE HEARD FROM
ME.
TUCKER, I DON'T WANT TO BE ON
HERE.
>> Tucker: I UNDERSTAND.
>> BUT WE HAVE TO BE HERE.
NOBODY IS STANDING UP FOR THE
KIDS.
IF THE KIDS GROW UP TRANSGENDER
AND 80 YEARS OLD AND HAPPY,
THAT'S GREAT.
A LOT OF KIDS GET CAUGHT UP IN
THIS HUGE TIDAL WAVE OF POPULAR
TRANSGENDER CULTURE AND IDEOLOGY
AND THAT WRONG.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU EXPRESSED AS
THE OPPOSITE OF HATE.
IT'S MEASURED, THOUGHTFUL AND
BORN OF YOUR OWN EXPERIENCE AND
MEASURED BY GOOD FAITH.
I HOPE IT'S SEEN BY EVERY ONE.
IT'S NOT POLITICAL.
CHRIS BECK, I APPRECIATE Y